non-minimalists
what's your advice for situations when
you had a
clear vision to achieve success slash
happiness but it falls apart due
to external forces how do you rebuild
yourself and restructure the idea of
success
in your head interesting that someone's
happiness
and success they made it one word
literally
yeah is and it falls apart due to
external forces
always yeah hmm right so so let me give
you my pithy answer maybe we can unpack
this together ryan
happiness is not a byproduct of success
it is a byproduct of enough
we don't ever stop to consider what is
enough yeah in our culture it's always
more
more more and and we rarely stop to
consider less because that almost seems
that's counter cultural you and i never
set out to be
counter-cultural as the minimalists but
in a way
it is a rejection of a consumerism
culture
because we realized exactly what cia was
saying here
success slash happiness which by the way
she puts it as one word because it's
success slash
happiness well that's the problem we've
attached happiness
to success now that's a foolish thing
for us to do
the reason that we call our audience
simpletons by the way because ryan and i
are the head simpletons
simpleton just means that we're we're
foolish right and what is the
most foolish thing that i have done in
my life well perhaps the most foolish is
i equated success with happiness as soon
as i get that thing
that external thing that person or thing
then i will be happy
and then when i'm happy i'll be actually
the other way around then i'll be
successful and as soon as i'm successful
then i will be happy of course it falls
apart
due to external forces that's how it
always falls
apart here's one more pity answer for
you ryan he who settles for success
is a successful hence the title of this
episode
so all i'm really trying to say here
ryan is that
when we pursue success when we pursue
happiness it is a type of failure we're
going to address this on the private
podcast i got a whole essay called
success does not exist and i have an
equation in there i know how you love
math equations i love it
and so i will prove to you
mathematically how success
equals failure ryan you got some of the
pithy for us
i do uh love is the foundation upon
which
success is built let me tell you why i
love this ryan
because what you're doing here is you're
redefining the culture's idea of success
yeah i mean when i think about me being
a successful person
it has nothing to do with titles or
followers or you know money it has
everything to do with
can i be myself 100 can i be who ryan
nicodemus is and do i have people in my
life who i can support and also be
supported by
and that is uh that's a good life and
you could put a million dollars in my
bank account or take
all my money away um having those things
for me helps me feel uh
i guess yeah successful yeah so there's
nothing wrong with
success the problem is hey the
definition
the meaning that we give success and b
like what are we
putting aside to chase that success
so going back to the corporate world we
associated success with happiness
yes but how many of our values did we
step on
how many things did we ignore in order
to be successful chasing the happiness
and arguably we got there but
yeah you know happiness is ephemeral we
we paid that cost
right and then realized like oh this
isn't worth
the cost that we're paying because of
all the additional calls
it first looked like okay work 60 hours
a week but then
all the other calls were stress and
anxiety and overwhelm and
and you end up in a place where you
don't want to be
well how do you end up there because you
chase success around success ryan
it's like when you take a balloon and
blow it up and you just let it go
um and all of a sudden we're just
chasing it all over the room right
if you ever do that with i've done it
with ella a bunch of times where i'll
just blow up a balloon and let it
and she'll try to chase it she'll never
ever catch it
but what a perfect metaphor for
happiness is you already had the
happiness right there
and you let it go and you start chasing
it you never
ever catch it it's like uh
well it's making me think there's
there's something there with a metaphor
about ella having a lot of fun
with the chase which then makes me think
about a dog that chases its tail they
get so excited but when they
as soon as they catch their tail they're
like now what they're confused
right right yeah and by the way that's
what happened to me and you
we caught our tail in our 20s yeah
and it was like oh wait a minute
now now what do i do i've caught the you
know what i
i need a bigger tail to catch now right
yeah
uh and and so it always sort of success
or happiness is always sort of right
around the bin
we never ever get there there's there
there is something about
never getting there though the there's
something about the chase that is fun
yeah but it's so so the question is is
that and and i don't know the answer to
this
is we're always chasing something like i
am chasing
uh peace right now so i think we're
always chasing something
you are chasing good health right now
you're you're uh
so i guess the question is like do we do
we accept
that we shouldn't chase or do we be more
deliberate with the things we chase